[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SUZI ESZTERHAS: Thank
you for having me.
So as Peter already
told you, I'm
a wildlife photographer,
which pretty much means
I have the best job on
earth, in many ways.
In some ways, maybe not so
great, as Peter mentioned
the financial side.
But in terms of
adventure and joy,
I've got a pretty good
gig with what I do.
I travel the world
taking photos of animals.
I do this for magazine
publications and book projects.
And my favorite projects
are for in-depth stories
where I spend time with
one animal, or one species,
anywhere from a few days, to
a few weeks, to few months.
And in the case of
cheetahs, 18 months.
So a lot of my time goes
to spending long hours
with my subjects, and really
creating in-depth work
that maybe we haven't seen
before, very rare imagery.
And it's having
these special times
with animals and long
time with animals that
really makes this possible.
I make my living from a
few different sources.
As I mentioned, I do magazines,
I do books, I also lead tours.
As a wild life
photographer, you have
to have a lot of
balls in the air.
And whatever comes
down is great,
and you're lucky some things
work, some things don't.
But there's no wildlife
photography career
where you can just
do one thing anymore,
where you're photographing
for one publication.
You've got to have a lot of
different projects going on.
But the one commonality is
that I focus on baby animals.
So I specialize in documenting
family life of wild animals,
and that is something that
I was born passionate about,
according to my mom.
She always says that this job--
you didn't pick this
job, it chose you.
Ever since I can remember,
this is all I wanted to do.
I don't know what it's
like to live life and not
want to photograph animals.
I was definitely a strange kid.
I didn't quite fit in school.
I wasn't exactly
popular with the boys,
or stylish, as you can see.
But I was passionate.
I was madly passionate
about animals, about nature.
This looks somewhere
really exotic,
but it's actually a zoo.
But I am dressed for
Safari, just in case.
And I've spent my life dreaming
about places like the African
Savannah.
And I told my parents
that I was going
to go live in a tent
in Africa, and I
think they thought I
would grow out of it.
But I never did.
And so, I grew up
in the Bay Area.
I grew up in San Rafael.
And then I went to Boulder
for a couple of years,
and then finished my
school in Santa Cruz.
And Santa Cruz was
a great place for me
to start off as a young
nature photographer.
I did a lot of local work.
Obviously, I didn't really
have when I graduated college--
you can't just graduate
college and say
I'm going to be a
wildlife photographer.
It's a bit like
saying, I'm going
to be an actor, or a musician.
You need a day job.
So I worked at the
Santa Cruz SPCA
as the PR director,
which basically
meant I got to hang out with
puppies and kittens all day,
which was better than my
previous job of waiting tables.
So I was pretty
happy about this.
And I held this
job for six years.
And in that six
year time, I managed
to get my schedule to
be four days a week,
and then I would go out and
shoot for three days a week.
And I really, really worked
on my portfolio, mostly local,
at the time.
As I started to work
with local subjects,
I started to realize how
important that connection was
with the animals,
in terms of focusing
on one animal in depth,
sometimes one individual,
but certainly one species,
and saw the value in that.
And I started producing
material, again, mostly focused
around baby animals.
And I started to hear
for the first time
that you can't make a career
in focusing on baby animals.
I mean, first of all, you can't
be a wild life photographer.
That's just a pie
in the sky dream.
But particularly, when I
threw in the baby animals,
people sort of pooh poohed it.
Baby animals are not
something that people
held in wide respect.
It was like, oh, that's for
kids, and you'll never make it.
And so I heard that
from the very beginning.
And honestly, I was so
driven and so passionate
about my subjects, that
I just didn't care.
I just completely
disregarded it.
I almost like
didn't even hear it.
And that drive-- you
have to have that
to make it in this industry.
You have to be
completely 100% driven.
You need that tunnel vision.
You need that ability to not
pay attention to rejection,
and not pay attention to
what people are saying,
and that extreme dedication.
Photographing wildlife
is not always easy.
It takes a lot of
patience, which I'll
talk about more in depth later.
But it also takes
a lot of skill,
and there's a lot of things
that you wouldn't necessarily
realize in it.
There's different ways of
approaching different subjects.
Some of the animals,
you have to hide from,
so I started using blinds
a lot, also called hides.
Dressing from camo from head
to toe for certain subjects.
And being in a blind
is really interesting.
You sit in there all day.
Sometimes, you're in a
crunched up a little position,
and you're waiting for
something to happen.
And sometimes, it's hot
and sweaty in there.
It's muddy.
And it's generally
not a fun experience.
So everybody has all these
ideas of wildlife photography
being super sexy.
You get to go to
all these places
and gallivant around the world
and you're with wild animals
all the time.
And the truth of the
matter is, is you're
doing stuff like this,
sitting in a blind--
hours and hours of boredom--
I wouldn't be honest if I
didn't admit that I get bored--
and waiting for something that
may or may not happen after you
spent a 13 hour a day.
And then, if you actually think
about what happens in those 13
hours, you can't always--
sometimes you can read a book,
but sometimes, in
this case, it's
too dark inside to read a book.
So you sit in there and just
try to get into this zen space.
And working with
baby animals, there
are particular-- if you're
at a den site, for example,
you can't cause a
lot of disturbance.
So often, you just sort of go in
really very quietly and slowly
in the morning, and
then you pull out
when the sun goes down.
And you don't go in and out.
There's no like going in
and out to pee privilege.
So you do things, like carry
around a big, huge, red water
bottle that is your
pee bottle, that
is a nice color that you could
never mistake as your water.
This is your life.
This is what you're doing.
You make that mistake once.
You accidentally
drink out of it once.
You never do it again.
You cover things with
stickers-- do not drink.
Various things that you just
don't think about as life
as a wildlife photographer.
And some of these places that
you go are sort of like these
legendary-- when I
first went up to Alaska,
and had the ability
to travel, you start--
you read about working with
these dangerous animals
on foot.
And grizzly bears can
kill you, and they charge.
And then, you start
sort of realizing
that yeah, animals like this can
be dangerous, but a lot of that
is sort of this almost urban
legend, mythical folklore.
Working with grizzly
bears has actually
been some of the most
peaceful experiences I've
had working with any subject.
And I learned this
really early on.
Grizzly bears were my
first large carnivore
working around getting to
know how to work with them.
And I was with a bear
guide who taught me a lot.
He was a bear hunter.
We carried bear
spray, at the time.
And what I realized is, is
that knowing animal behavior
is 90% of this job.
And this was good for
me, because it was always
90% of my interest.
The photography
kind of came second.
It was the animals
that came first.
But knowing that actually
part of the skill,
or the majority of
the skill, is knowing
what these animals might do,
in terms of keeping you safe,
but also in terms
of what they might
do in getting the
photo the next time,
anticipating what
they're going to do next.
So historically, you'd think,
OK, working with mom and cubs,
with grizzly bears is something
that is quite dangerous,
but really if you
know their behavior,
you keep your distance,
you're respectful
and you know signs
to watch for--
I use a lot of long lenses--
it can be incredibly
peaceful experience,
where you're not in danger
and they're not stressed.
And that's one of the
most important things when
I work, particularly since
I work with baby animals,
is not stressing
my subjects out.
Because obviously, this is
a really tender sensitive
situation when you're working
with animals and they're young.
And some of these
young mammals that
grow up around people-- this
is a sub-adult grizzly bear
that grew up around people.
And we have various strategies
when working with grizzly
bears if they get too curious.
So you have bear spray
around your belt,
but you don't want
to use the bear spray
unless you absolutely have to.
So the Bears will come up
and get curious about you.
And they'll kind of try
to sniff your backpack
or whatever they want to do.
And you, obviously, will
slowly back away and try,
if you're with other people,
you try to sort of stay together
as a group.
And then, sometimes,
the bears that
have grown up around
people, they're not really
easily phased, so you
might do something
like shake a rain jacket at
them, which makes a loud noise,
and then they usually run away.
Or in this bear's case, he had
heard a lot of rain jackets.
He was not fazed by
rain jackets at all,
so he just kept coming
and coming and coming.
And then finally, I just took
my baseball cap off my head
and bonked him on
the nose with it,
and that was the end of that.
So a baseball hat
is what it takes
for this large and dangerous
carnivore to go running away.
So some of the job has
really been dispelling
a lot of those myths.
And I'm not saying that these
aren't dangerous animals,
but there are very peaceful
ways of working with them
and coexisting.
One of the other exotic places
I got to go was the Arctic.
This is my first experience
with really extreme conditions.
I went up to document
a climate change study.
And part of that was
actually the scientists
were darting mothers and cubs
as they came out of their den.
And so the scientist
had a cub that
was getting a little too cold.
It was tranquilized and its
body temperature was dropping.
And he's like, are you
OK with warming him up?
I'm like, sure.
I'm not going to say no to that.
I had a job on a
ship in Antarctica.
I worked on a staff
for two expeditions.
And that was a little bit
of a-- it was a fun job.
It didn't pay well, but I
got to photograph penguins
on my off time, and then was
assisting with zodiac loading
and unloading on my work time.
But for me, as a young wildlife
photographer starting out,
it was a job that was
a dream job because I
had a paid trip to
Antarctica and I
got to photograph animals.
I was already selling
pictures, at this point,
and I had already established
a relationship with an agent.
And when I got home from that,
my agent sold one of my photos
to the cover of "Time."
and it was a really
interesting point in my career.
Two things happened.
One, I knew that the job
didn't pay that well.
At that time, I was $50,000
in credit card debt,
and that was from just
trying to get started.
There was there was no--
you can't get a business
loan as a wildlife photographer
and there was no family money,
so credit cards, to
me, were worth gold.
And so, I put everything on a
credit card to buy all the gear
and do some of the
first travel that I did.
So I knew that this was
not a high-paying job,
but I hadn't really realized
how bad it actually was.
And so, when I got this
message from my agent
that this had sold, I
thought, I'm going to be rich.
This is amazing.
Cover of "Time,"
worldwide rights--
I'm going to be a rich girl.
And I had all these numbers
in my head, and in the end,
it was $1,500 split
between the two of us.
And that was a major
eye opener for me.
And then, the other eye opener
that came with the "Time,"
cover as well was--
you know, you get the cover of
"Time," and so a lot of people
start talking about, OK, well,
the photographer has arrived.
They've had the cover of "Time."
And for me, it was the
first time I really realized
I'd-- obviously, being a woman
in a male dominated field,
I had been a minority.
And I had experienced some of
the challenges faced with that.
But this is when
I really started
to hear discussions about
me, said in front of me,
of she'll be barefoot and
pregnant in five years.
She's not going to last.
She'll have kids.
She's a woman.
She's not going to
go to tough places.
And it really--
the conversations
after this "Time" cover came
out, were quite eye opening
for me, in terms of exactly
what an old boys club
I was dealing with.
My big break came at a really
interesting point in my life.
I had been saving money, instead
of paying off my credit card
debt, which I should have been.
I was saving money to do
a dream project, which
was to go to Africa and
photograph a cheetah cub
family.
I wanted to follow cubs
that were out of the nest,
like six weeks old or so.
And I'd put money
aside for that and I'd
made some relationships
with people in Africa
about certain places
where cheetahs were found.
And I had convinced
these lodge owners
to let me know when there was
a litter of cheetah cubs out.
And it had been a couple
years since I had, had
any correspondence with them.
And at the time, I was
still working my SPCA job.
I was part time, but I
was still working it.
And I was feeling a
little demoralized
about my career,
and whether or not
it was going to
actually work for me.
And there were other
challenges in my life, as well.
I was-- I think, every woman, at
some point, has a bad boyfriend
and this was my time to
have a bad boyfriend.
I had this guy for seven years
that I shouldn't have been with
and life just was not
really going well.
And bing, comes into my
inbox an e-mail saying
there's cheetah cubs,
come to the Serengeti now.
And I decided overnight to
radically change my life.
So I dumped the boyfriend.
I drained the savings account.
I put everything in
storage, and I picked up,
and I went to Africa.
And I thought I'd stay two
years, and I wound up staying--
sorry-- I thought
I'd stay two months,
and I wound up
staying three years.
And it radically
changed my life.
I wound up spending 18
months working with Cheetahs,
five different families.
This is a family I
worked with when--
I actually found the mom
when she was pregnant
and worked with these guys.
They are about four days old.
And I started getting imagery
that was really unique.
And what I would
do in order to get
this imagery is I would go out
and I would find my cheetah
family in the morning
and I would stay
with them all day
long until sunset,
and then, I had one of those
old-fashioned GPS point
devices, not like the Garmin
where it tells you like,
turn right to go
to the cheetahs.
There wasn't anything
like that, but I
would plot in points
at the end of the day.
And so, the next day, I would
go back and try to find them.
And I did this over and
over again every day.
And I got to know quite a few
different females very well.
And as a result, their
cubs grew up around me
and started you doing things
like playing on my car,
on the tire, and then
I had a cheetah jump
on the hood of my car.
This is a cub that
grew up around me.
And then, he eventually
progressed to the point
where he would stick his head
in my window that was open.
And cheetahs are very docile.
They're not like
lions or leopards
where they're going
to full on attack you,
so you don't have to be
terrified when this happens.
But, he stuck his
head in the window
and pawed my shoulder to try
to get me to engage in play.
And of course, as a wildlife
photographer, we don't touch.
It's not something that we do.
It's a real ethical no,
no, so I didn't play back,
as much as I wanted to.
I didn't play back.
Or I would just be
sitting there in my car
and he'd be on the roof and
his tail would drop down
and graze my neck, and it was
quite a heavenly experience.
And then, followed the moms
when they went out hunting.
This is a shot that was
incredibly difficult
for me to get.
I think I tried for
about 12 days or so.
And she finally had a
hunt that was in the open,
and in a right situation
for photography.
And just being able to
capture these animals
at such high speeds
is something that's
challenging, but also
really exhilarating
watching a cheetah move.
And you can see here
in her movement,
her tail is like
a rudder and she's
using it to turn as
this gazelle zigzags
and tries to escape from her.
So just really
incredibly special times
with my cheetah families.
And then I found myself at
the end of those 18 months,
I found myself thinking, well,
I'm in the Masai Mara, which
is one of the wildlife meccas,
and so I thought well, turn
my attention to the 1.8 million
wildebeests that were pouring
in, and do the great migration.
Worked with Leopard.
And then spent a few months
working with a lion pride.
This is one of my
top selling images.
This is a male meeting his
cub for the first time.
And again, this went back
to knowing wildlife behavior
and knowing what
might happen next.
So I had done a lot of research.
I had talked to a lot
of different biologists.
And I knew that when
I found the cubs
they were about two weeks old,
and I knew that at some point,
mom would take them out, or more
like mom couldn't keep them in,
and they'd be so
rowdy they'd come out.
She couldn't do
anything about it.
And they would meet
the rest of the pride.
And that would be
when they met dad.
So I anticipated this
moment and just hoped
that it would happen, and in a
good situation for photography.
And on a day when I could find
them, because lots of times
I would go out looking
for my subjects
and not be able to find
them, and look all day
and have no success.
So luck plays a huge part in it.
Anticipation plays a huge
part, but luck as well.
And then that patience game of--
a lot of the big
cats that I work with
aren't very shy because they're
used to people on safari
following them around.
But when you start
working with some
of the nondescript animals,
like these jackals--
you start following them
and they're like, whoa,
you're supposed to ignore me.
What's going on?
And they don't like it one bit.
So for this family, it took
17 days to habituate them.
And what that means is
basically to get them
so that they're not shy anymore.
And so, 17 days until
I got my first photo.
And that's just moving
my jeep a little bit
closer to them every day.
A lot of people ask what my life
was like living in the Mara,
and this is the
car that I drove.
It was a little Suzuki.
When I first got there,
I had a Land Cruiser.
And the Land Cruiser
is a lot to handle.
It's a lot on my
own with my physique
to even just change the tire.
You grow up in Marin
and you called AAA.
There's AAA out
there, so you've got
to do everything on your own.
So this was a car
that I could handle
doing some small repairs
on, and also a great car
for driving around, following
wildlife, because I could get
into little places, as well.
People teased me because
it was like a toy car,
but it served me very well.
And then my camp.
This is my very
fancy bush shower.
At first, I just had
the rubber bucket
and tied it up in the trees.
And then I had my
camp guy make me this.
I did hire a security
guard for camp,
and he became sort
of my camp guy
and helped me with stuff around.
And then I had this
tent for three years.
So it's bigger than the kind of
tent you'd go to Yosemite in,
but still pretty basic.
There was a cot inside.
And then I had a basin
to wash with, as well.
No toilet-- living without
a toilet for three years
is quite an experience.
And then, I had no power for
the first year and a half.
I ran everything off
my car batteries.
And then, after a
year and a half,
I got solar panels put in.
So I don't know if you
noticed in the previous shot,
but there's a little
friend up in front.
But while I was working
in the Masai Mara,
the rangers got to know me.
And they asked me if I would
take care of an orphan servile
kitten, named Moto.
I named the Moto,
which means fire.
And I was pretty isolated
and kind of lonely
in camp, so I loved
the idea of having
a little something, a little
being to love and take care of.
So I said yes.
And the intent was always
to return him to the wild,
but he was two weeks old,
so he needed a lot of time
with a mom, of sorts.
So when I first got him,
he was not doing well.
He was emaciated and he
was not feeding very well,
and a rehabber had told
me that I just needed
to hang out with him in bed.
And I couldn't, at the time.
I was working on my hyena
den and I was too busy.
I couldn't just hang out
in bed for days with him,
so I sewed a little
kangaroo pouches into shirts
and tucked him inside
and buttoned him up.
And I would take him
in my Jeep everyday.
We'd go out to the hyena den.
And he loved it in the pouch.
He was super happy in there.
He would just snooze
away in the pouch.
He peed on me a lot in there.
But other than that, it
worked out really well.
And then bonded with me from
being so close to me for days
and hearing my heart
beat and feeling my skin.
Then he started
feeding very well.
He also loved being brushed
with an old toothbrush
that I had around.
And if you think about
it, it was perfect.
It was the exact shape
and size and texture
as mom's tongue would have been.
He absolutely could
not get enough of this.
So I did this every day.
And then, the really
tough part came
where I had to teach
him how to kill rats.
And that one was rough.
So I started--
I took him from milk formula
to chicken smoothies.
So I actually got a blender
and started blending up
chicken breast with the milk.
But then, I had to get
him on to something.
It's not like he'd find
raw chicken breast around
in the Mara, so I had to get
him on to something natural.
So I said to the rangers--
I put up a bounty
on rats, and said
if you can bring me a dead
rat-- the only rule was
no poison was
allowed-- then I'll
give you a certain
amount of money.
So the day I put the
bounty up, the next day
I had seven dead rats
with people's names
all written out of
who I owed money to.
And then the stakes got
higher, because he immediately
got the hang of what a rat--
like, what the taste is,
and he got the taste for it.
But he didn't know quite
what to do with them,
in terms of killing them.
And what mom would
do is she would
take something maimed or
crippled back to the nest
for them, or take them out to
something maimed or crippled.
And so, I knew I had to give him
So it sounds really
horrible, but I
had to say, well, I'll give
you double the amount of money
if you give me a crippled rat.
So I got these brown bags
with crippled rats inside.
And the first crippled
rat I gave him,
it took him 45
minutes to kill it.
And he killed it by
just beating it to death
on the floor of my tent.
It was like a crime scene.
There was blood everywhere.
It was terrible.
But he eventually
got the hang of it
and became the most
amazing rat hunter.
And he thrived.
And he did very well.
To the day that he left, he
actually loved being in my car.
I think it's from all
the time in the pouch.
There were no fences in
my camp, so he was seeing
all those wild animals around.
But he loved, for some reason,
he loved looking at the animals
through the window.
So he'd always try
to hop in my car
whenever he could to go out
on a game drive with me.
So sometimes I would let him.
He did go back to the wild.
He just disappeared one night.
He used to-- by the time he
left, he was pretty feisty
and had reached sexual maturity
and was very aggressive,
but he still was
coming in every night.
And he would cuddle
up to me, and purr,
and lick me for a few
minutes every night,
and then he'd go
off hunting again.
I left the zip open in the
tent, so it was like a cat door.
It actually worked as a snake
door, too, unfortunately.
And he was supposed to be
good at catching snakes,
but he wound up being a
miserable snake hunter.
So that didn't work out so well.
But he would just leave,
come back as he pleased.
And then one night,
he didn't come.
And I just kind of
thought the worst,
but I saw him a week later,
and he was absolutely fine.
So he just returned
to the wild, which
is exactly what I
wanted him to do.
I don't know what I
thought-- like, maybe,
there'd be some
dramatic goodbye.
I'd never done anything
like this before.
I grew up with puppies
and kittens, you know?
And when they leave,
you usually say goodbye.
You put them to sleep,
and you say goodbye.
I thought there'd be
like goodbye, good luck,
but none of that.
But I was very happy
that he went to the wild.
That was the point
the whole time.
So I'm not going to get
too doom and gloom, but one
of the things that
this experience also
gave me was my first
experience with conservation
and conservation photography.
So one of the things that I
realized is that there was
poaching going on absolutely
everywhere where I had been,
but I had never seen
any signs of it,
because as a sort of
tourist, you don't.
But then I would come back
and talk to the rangers
and they'd talk about
catching eight poachers
on [INAUDIBLE] hill.
And I'm like, well,
wait a minute.
I was on [INAUDIBLE]
hill yesterday.
And so I started
to sort of marvel
at how invisible poaching was.
And I started to ask could
I come with you on some
of the anti-poaching jobs?
And, of course, first,
the answer was no.
Again, that went back
to being a woman--
that it wasn't
safe to be a woman.
And the nice thing about
Africans and their sexism
is that they're
pretty point blank.
They don't try to hide it.
They're like no.
It's because you're a woman,
and there's no place for you.
Whereas in our culture, we try
to hide it a little bit more.
But they don't.
They just come
right out with it.
And they're like no.
But after two years, I convinced
them to allow me to come,
and they did.
So I spent three weeks
shadowing these guys.
And we would go out on these--
some of them are just patrols,
patrolling for snares.
And then others were a little
more exciting than that,
and they were actual ambushes.
So we would go and we
would find the meat hanging
in a camp where the guys were
sort of packing it in and out,
coming back and forth.
They had to walk two
days with the meat.
So we'd see where meat was
hanging and drying in the trees
and you'd know they
were going to come back,
so we'd lay in the grass
and wait all night.
And there were sometimes
when I'd go out with them
and nothing exciting
would happen-- just lay
there all night,
and a hyena would
chew on your shoe, or
something, and that
was like the only
excitement-- guys never came.
And then there were other
nights where stuff would happen.
So with these raids, most of
what these guys were doing
is commercial meat poaching.
And it was going at
a really rapid rate.
So you they estimated that
year, 180,000 wildebeests
had been poached in the
Serengeti Mara ecosystem.
And that year, the total
population was 1.8 million.
So in terms of the
sustainability of the trade,
and the volume that
we were dealing with,
it was pretty out of control.
A lot of it was
going on at night.
And so, the night ambushes
that would happen,
it was really difficult.
The guys didn't
have night-vision equipment.
They had-- a lot of them-- there
were some AK 47s in the mix,
but a lot of them just had old
rifles that they hadn't shot
in 10 years--
very underfunded.
They had a couple handcuffs.
The rest of them used some twine
that they put guys together
with.
On this raid, there were
52 poachers that night.
And we had 40 guys on
foot, and six vehicles,
and the poachers came in.
We watched them coming
down from the escarpment
for a couple of hours.
And then, they came in
and all hell broke loose.
People were running
everywhere-- chaos.
And in the end,
12 were captured.
So it's a very
challenging thing.
And it's also a very
demoralizing thing
for the rangers
themselves to hear.
They were out 52
poachers and they got 12.
It's not exactly a success
rate that they can be proud.
There were days when we would
go around collecting snares,
and there would be, at the end
of the day, over 300 snares.
So huge, huge volume.
After my time in the Mara, I
started doing a lot of work
in jungles with apes.
And apes are really fun.
They're pretty
exciting to work with.
I always describe
chimpanzees as schizophrenic.
One second, they're calm, and
then the next second, they're
just completely psycho.
And the alpha males are the
worst at it, unfortunately.
And I was warned--
so this guy, his
name is Cacama, and I
was warned when I started
working in this area,
that Cacama might give me a
little grief when he met me.
And I didn't really know
exactly what that looked like.
But the Ugandan research
assistants had said,
if he charges you, you
need to kick at him,
and then he'll stop.
And so, trying to
describe what it's
like to be charged by a
chimpanzee is really difficult.
When they start charging, they
get into this-- first of all,
they get bipedal.
And second of all, their
hair stands up on end
and it's piloerect.
It looks like they've
been electrocuted,
and it's from all the
aggressive hormone that's
just pumping through them.
And then they take branches
with them, usually,
as they're running.
They're like carrying
the force with them.
They throw rocks often.
And they beat the ground.
And I tell you, when
a chimp like this
comes straight at you, you would
have to be like super human
to be able to kick at it.
I could not kick at
him when he did this.
And so as a result
of me not kicking,
which everybody found
hilarious except me,
is Cacama gave me a bit
of a slap as he went by.
He just went, whap, and
slapped me on the hip,
and then kept going,
which was quite alarming.
It didn't really hurt, but
it was pretty terrifying.
And then, all the guys
thought it was hilarious.
The head researcher wasn't
so excited about it.
The guy from Harvard,
because obviously,
you don't want to have
any physical contact.
Aggression tends to build
in chimpanzee societies,
so it wasn't the greatest
thing that happened,
but it was terrifying,
to say the least.
So Cacama, who was like this
big, huge, brutal alpha male
is the polar
opposite of this guy.
This is Alonjo.
And when I first
entered this field,
I'd heard people talk
about animal crushes.
And I had thought these
people are so bushed out,
they have spent way too
much time with animals,
until I developed my
first animal crush, which
is what with Alonjo.
And Alonjo stole my
heart immediately.
I mean, you have to admit, he's
a pretty sexy looking chimp.
And he's very charming.
He's grown up around
people, so he has
absolutely no fear of people.
And he likes to look at
you with these gazing eyes.
And then he does this thing
where he puts his arm out,
and he puts out
his palm, and it's
like grooming solicitation.
It's what chimpanzees, when they
say to each other, groom me.
So he would come up
to me and do this.
And of course, we don't touch.
We can't do this,
but I desperately
wanted to groom Alonjo.
And there was another
American research student
there at the time,
my friend, Jess.
And so, one day, I confessed
my crush for Alonjo.
And she's like,
oh, my god, me too.
He's such a good-looking chimp.
And so, then after that, we
kept like, I saw Alonjo today.
You did not.
So we had the thing
going about Alonjo.
Animals do get under
your skin sometimes.
Alonjo's one of them that did.
So then I moved on to
photographing orangutans,
and this is something that
is very close to my heart.
Orangutans, as many
of you probably know,
are in peril from
palm oil, which
is in a lot of Western
products that we use,
food products and toiletries.
And so I set off on a quest to
photograph an orangutan rescue.
And the orangutans that we
found that needed to be rescued
were in a patch of land that was
fragmented and was surrounded
by clear cut, and so there was
no way these orangutans could
live on it.
And I went out with these guys.
This was the rescue team
that I went out with,
and we drove into the village.
They dropped me off at
a little guest house
where they thought I'd be
more comfortable staying.
They went into the village
to stay at somebody's house.
And at 10:00 at
night, one of them
came back, looking
absolutely terrified saying
they were fleeing, because
they had gotten death threats,
and that I had to hide
there, because it wasn't safe
for me to leave with them, and
that they didn't think anyone
knew I was associated with them,
but I shouldn't leave my room.
And they would send an unmarked
car for me the next morning.
So it was quite an
eye-opening experience,
in terms of what these
guys are dealing with.
And I'm sitting there having
to text my fiance saying,
the number for the State
Department and my passport
copies are on the desk,
and blah, blah, blah.
I didn't know it
was going to happen.
Nothing happened.
Everything was fine.
They sent an unmarked car.
I got out of the village
without any problems.
But the palm oil
industry is something
that is absolutely--
it's like big tobacco
or big oil in this country.
It's quite corrupt.
And it's quite
scary for the locals
that have to deal with it.
So we moved to another village,
stayed in an Islamic community.
And for me, I was
with those 12 guys,
and what was great is the
Islamic faith is obviously
very modest, so
because I was a woman,
they gave me the
bedroom, which is great,
except there's no bed.
But it was super
comfortable, nonetheless.
And I stayed in this house.
The bathing was not ideal.
The bathroom, for showering
and whatnot, wasn't great.
But this is often the
conditions that we're
in as wildlife photographers.
We're either in the
bush, or were often
in villages that are
incredibly impoverished
and we don't complain and
we're just really grateful
about everything that we're
given, particularly these guys,
because these guys are
risking their lives.
A lot of them are informants
and they're actually
snitching out people
in their community
about these
orangutans being sold.
So one of the things that
happens with orangutans that
are on palm oil plantations
is that the babies are
sold on the black market
as pets and there's
a lot of money involved in this.
So the informants are
usually snitching them out
when they know a baby's
in somebody's house that's
going to be sold.
So we did rescue an orangutan
on this parceled piece of forest
and took her to a
national park where
she could live safely
and have enough food.
The big thing about being
on a palm oil plantation
is that they can't survive.
Orangutans can't live off
palm, and so they slowly
starve to death, if they're not
shot by the palm oil plantation
workers.
So she was released.
So that was a happy story.
And then I have worked a lot
with some much lighter-hearted,
goofy animals.
Sloths are one of my favorites.
I've spent close to eight
years working on sloths,
and recently did a sloth book.
And one of the things that we--
the sloth researcher and I
really wanted to document
are these swimming
slots that live
on an island off of Panama,
about three hours off shore.
And it was quite an adventure
going to photograph them.
And I had never done any
underwater photography before,
so I was pretty intimidated
by this whole thing.
I'd never used an
underwater housing.
And so, photographers,
like any other field,
when you don't know how to
do something, you practice.
So this is the pool
in my backyard.
And this teddy bear has
been various animals for me.
He's posed as penguins in trees.
He's posed as
koala joeys getting
a surgery in a hospital, just
trying to figure out techniques
of how I would shoot something.
So I stuck some floaties
on this teddy bear,
in order to figure
out how I was going
to shoot the cover of our book.
And then there is India.
And India was a project
that for me took 2 and 1/2
years of negotiating
with Indian National
Parks and the
government, and that
was to try to photograph
a wild Tiger den.
And I had one huge disadvantage,
and that was being a woman.
And India is one
of the worst places
that I've worked in, in
terms of being a woman.
I'm very careful when I
travel to other cultures.
I always dress according to
the way I should be dressed.
And I act the way
I should be acting.
If you're a woman
traveling alone,
I think that there's
no other way to do it.
But it was quite
difficult for me,
because I just was not
getting any headway.
And then, one of my closest
Indian friends said to me,
you just need to hire
a male project manager,
and stop trying to
go to the meetings
yourself, and just have
him do everything for you.
And that solved
absolutely everything.
It's one of the few
places where I've actually
gone into government
meetings and I've
been told that I can't
go into the meeting
because I'm a woman, and it
was a government official
that told me that.
So it's a challenging
environment, for that respect.
I absolutely love
the Indian culture.
I love the Indian people.
And I loved working with
my Indian tiger den.
So this was in a place called
Bandhavgarh National Park,
and this was a very
special project for me,
not just in terms of how
rare it is to get permission
to work with a wild tiger den,
but the fact that this female
was super relaxed, and
eventually her cubs
also accepted me as well.
This is the natal den
where she gave birth.
So you can see in
the next image that's
her going back up into it.
She stayed in her natal den
for about the first month,
and then moved her cubs
to an even better place
for photography.
And this shot was
really interesting,
because she had moved them to
a place that was quite high,
actually.
It was like a cave, and
she liked to lay out
on the front of the cave area.
And in order to get
the shot, I had to--
I was working on an elephant.
When you work with tigers,
you're on elephant back,
usually, in India.
And there's a long history
of good relationship
between elephant and tigers
in the national parks
and the tiger reserves.
And so, I am on
this elephant back,
and I had to stand up in
order to get the shot.
And my elephant [INAUDIBLE]
is holding onto my legs.
And he's like,
please don't fall.
Please don't fall.
And I stood there
and was able to get
these photos that kind of
gave you that feeling of being
in the den.
And that was just because mom
liked to cool off up front.
So again, luck playing a
huge part of it as well.
And then I did a lot of work
on the cubs as they grew up.
So one of the things that I
would just like to end on.
I know I've talked a
couple times about being
a woman in this
field, but it's being
a minority in the field
has been something
that's incredibly challenging.
And it's slowly changing.
There are more and
more young women
getting into nature photography
than there used to be.
When I entered it was very
much an old boy's club.
It still very much is.
There's still a lot of
sexism in the field.
There's a lot of sexual
harassment as well.
But things are changing.
And I decided two years ago
to start my own nonprofit.
So I started
something called Girls
Who Click and it's dedicated
to trying to encourage
young women to enter the
field of nature photography,
either as a profession
or as a hobby
or as a part of another job.
But just trying to
get girls into this
and get them outside
with a camera.
And that's been
incredibly rewarding
working with the girls.
We provide free
workshops for teen girls.
And then we a lot of the top
names in nature photography
that are women are
working as instructors.
So it's something that is
incredibly close to my heart
that I'm very proud of, and
that's called Girls Who Click.
And that is it.
That's all I've got for you.
Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Any questions?
AUDIENCE: I'm from India, and
it's incredibly disappointing
to hear that experience.
SUZI ESZTERHAS: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: On behalf of
my countrymen and women.
If it makes you
feel any better, I
have tried getting permission to
use a Rover to take photographs
and I've never gotten permission
so far, even being a man.
The question I had was, from
a conservation perspective,
increasingly many more people
are visiting national parks
and they're taking
pictures of wild animals.
So there's a lot
more information
in social media, a lot
more images and pictures.
So people kind of tend
to lose perspective
that there is extreme
threat and danger for some
of these animals.
Like tigers, for
example, today, you
go to [INAUDIBLE] or
Bandhavgarh and you
spend two or three
safaris, or you
go to [INAUDIBLE]
into the forest,
it's a guarantee that you'll
definitely see a tiger.
And many of them
carry good equipment
and they shoot pictures.
But the truth is, there
only about 2,700 tigers
in the country.
And it's the largest tiger
population in the world.
There's so much
images of that, people
don't have that perception that
this natural history is pretty
much under severe threat.
We need to do
something about it.
What is your
perspective on that?
SUZI ESZTERHAS: I
think, that's definitely
one way to look at it.
The other way--
So first of all, I think there's
a lot of validity in that.
And what I would
say is a lot of this
is how you use the pictures.
And one of the things
with Girls Who Click
and also the way I
operate is not just
collecting pretty pictures,
and using these pictures
for conservation.
So I do a tremendous
amount of work
with conservation organizations
and raising money and also
awareness.
And so, trying to use your
pictures to elevate awareness,
rather than just--
let's just say you're posting
these photos on social media.
Rather than just posting
a pretty photo of a tiger,
trying to also post, maybe
not every time, but at least
sometimes, every
once in while, post
some really critical information
about how many tigers are left.
And also, what I
try to do is when
I do post about
conservation, I try
to tell people what they can
do, because otherwise people
wind up feeling a
little bit helpless.
It's very easy right
now in this climate
to feel helpless about a
lot of different things
that are going on.
So giving people
something to do,
some direct action
they can take,
and your photos can
actually utilize-- they
can bring that home even
more, than if you posted that.
Let's think of posting that
without an image, right?
Not that many people would see
it, because it's just text.
But if you post that with a
pretty photo, it gets shared
and it gets shared again.
So I think a lot of it is
how you use the photos.
But that's one of the
things that I really
am trying to teach
the girls in Girls Who
Click is that this is
not about just collecting
pretty pictures.
This is about doing
something good
with your photos that's
going to benefit the world
and the animals that are in it.
So that is a fair point.
We see also a lot-- you're
absolutely right about tigers,
but we also see that with lions.
They didn't realize
until 10 years ago,
it kind of came as a
huge shock to the world
that lion numbers have
dramatically plummeted.
Because people, when
they go on safari,
they see lions everywhere.
But what they don't
realize is that outside
of the national parks, lions
are almost non-existent,
and it's only in
those little pockets.
So you get this false
impression that Africa
is teeming with lions when
you go over there on safari.
And you would get that
impression with the tigers
as well.
So again, I think it goes back
to how you use the images.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for coming here today.
So not even to reframe
that, but kind of
build on that last
question there--
in addition to
just the awareness
perspective, and desensitizing
it from other people,
or them feeling it's not as
though it's as big of an issue,
you just mentioned the
tourism and the parks
in Africa and whatnot.
Do you feel that because
of this awareness
and now more of a movement to
go and visit those in person,
that you're seeing
an encroachment
on the actual
habitats themselves?
I actually went on safari a
few years ago and noticed--
just the sheer number of
cars and the difficulties
it causes for the
lions themselves.
And if they're all
concentrated in that area,
do you see that this
awareness actually
might backfire in the sense
that all the tourism there
is going to continue to
destabilize their environment?
SUZI ESZTERHAS: Yeah,
that's a real catch-22.
I definitely witnessed
that firsthand
and continue to witness
that all over the world.
You see tourists,
irresponsible tourism,
not just tourists
behaving badly,
but the infrastructure
that's set up for
tourism not being ideal,
or being too crowded,
or not being green.
And that is a problem.
The flip side of it is that if
we cut off areas to tourism,
or if there aren't enough people
seeing them, we as human beings
tend to not care about something
unless we can enjoy it.
That's why wilderness
areas in this country
haven't really ever worked.
Wilderness areas are a
great idea in concept.
There's no roads
going through them.
The problem is people
can't enjoy them.
People tend to forget they exist
and they don't care about them.
Whereas, a threat it
happens in Yellowstone,
the whole world cares because
so many people have been there
and they care about it.
So it is I think
a real catch-22.
The answer is, obviously,
it's a no-brainer,
is controlling the tourism,
and controlling the numbers.
And that's a huge problem.
It's one of the biggest things
right now with jaguar tourism
in Brazil, a place where
I used to take people.
When I first started
going, we'd have
three or four boats around
a jaguar sighting maximum.
And last time I
went, there were 30.
And so that kind of
uncontrolled growth
is going to kill
it for everybody.
It's not good for the tigers and
it's terrible for the tourism.
So I think a lot of it
is about controlling it.
The problem comes
is that you have
these economies and these local
areas that are so impoverished,
that everybody wants to get
in on it, rightfully so.
But it's very difficult
to control that growth.
It has to come from
a government level,
and a lot of these
governments are just not
willing to do that.
Botswana is kind of
an interesting example
of controlled tourism,
however that's
only available for the
elite and for the wealthy.
So there's kind of a
catch-22s in all of it.
But I think that's
a really fair point,
that we have to control it.
AUDIENCE: Whether it's
photography or art or writing,
some sort of creative
endeavor, or developing
your creative talent,
there is that developing
your personal style.
And I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about maybe
how other photographers
have either influenced you,
or changed your own
style, or you perhaps
saw what they were doing
and tried to build on that,
or however that might be,
that helped you develop
your own creative style.
SUZI ESZTERHAS: So
when I was little,
I grew up watching
nature documentaries
and also reading magazines.
But I really loved
nature documentaries.
And when I was in college, I
did a semester abroad program,
and I had the ability
to work with a film crew
from the BBC for about two
weeks as a sort of apprentice
of sorts.
And they allowed me to go
back and work with them
on two occasions.
And I learned a tremendous
amount from them, particularly
about wildlife behavior and
about respecting animals,
and about working with
individuals and developing
relationships of trust between
yourself and the animal,
but also habituating
animals that are shy.
And I took from that--
a huge amount of
my work is based
on the way a cameraman operates
versus a stills photographer.
In fact, a lot of people
have told me, god, you
work a lot more like a film
crew would than a stills
photographer, just in terms
of the sheer amount of time
that I take with my subjects,
and also how in depth
and how much care I take in not
offending my animal subjects
or not threatening their trust.
So cameramen have been
hugely influential.
I wish all stills photographers
had spent some time
with cameramen, because
cameraman, for the most part,
are really--
they're in the trenches more
than still photographers,
in terms of how
much time they have
to spend waiting for a
shot and how much they have
to get into the animal's head.
But that's also something
that I'm most interested in.
So most of my early people that
I admired, with the exception--
there's a female
nature photographer
that I admired growing
up named Tui De Roy, who
is a huge mentor of
mine to this day,
and is someone that I am
privileged to call a friend.
She entered the industry when
there were almost no women.
And she stepped foot
very bravely into a world
where women were really
not welcome at all.
And I really admire her for it.
So I grew up admiring
her stuff as well.
AUDIENCE: Going back a little
bit to conservation issues,
you've had a lot of
contact with local people
who seem to really care
about these issues,
whether it be rangers or people
who are out there to protect
the orangutans near the
palm oil plantations,
and could you talk more
about what drives them?
Is it government initiatives
that pay those people as a way
to basically help protect
the preserves, or is it
just their interactions
with the animals
that they feel compelled
to protect them,
just to get a
sense of what works
and what doesn't
at the local level?
SUZI ESZTERHAS: I
think it depends.
I mean, it depends on the
conservation initiative.
I can think of ones
that I've worked
on where it has not been
driven by money at all
and the guys are just totally
in love with the wildlife
and care passionately
about what they're doing.
And then I can think
of others where
it's like they're just
going through it blind
and they just want the money.
And they're maybe
doing a good job,
but the passion is not there.
So it's all across the board.
I think that any program, not
any, but many programs that do
bring in together money and
conservation, they work,
because local communities
need the money
in many of these countries.
The biggest problems,
like the poachers
that I showed you
photos of, those
are Wakuria people in the
Serengeti National Park.
And one of the
reasons why they're
poaching in the
Serengeti National Park
is because they used to live
in the Serengeti National Park.
They were hunters and gatherers
and they got kicked out
by the government when it
was made a national park
and they're not employed
by the National Park.
The National Park employs
people from the cities,
instead of employing
local Wakuria people.
So they have absolutely
no economic benefit
from the park at all.
So they go into the
park to get what's
sort of rightfully
theirs and there's
no qualms about that,
because they're not
getting any benefit.
So why not?
So the conservation programs
that employ people and give
them a livelihood, I think, for
the most part, really do work.
I know there's some
situations where money doesn't
work in conservation,
but I think
they're few and far between.
AUDIENCE: I didn't quite catch
if you like writing articles
to go with your photographs,
or do you sometimes--
how you display the photographs,
or are you sometimes trying
to find a reporter to go
work on it with you, or just
what do you prefer,
or do you think
you'll be more doing more
writing with the photographs?
SUZI ESZTERHAS: I
don't like writing.
I grew up with two parents
that were journalists.
They were writers.
And I don't know, maybe that
gave me a distaste for it.
But just not in a
terrible way, but they
were writing a lot,
particularly my father.
But writing is something
I've never enjoyed,
and it's never
come easily to me.
It's something that usually
I dread it and put it
on the back burner.
I'd write for children's books.
That's very different.
It has been
challenging, for sure.
Writing for a
three-year-old is not easy,
especially when you've
never had a three-year-old.
But in terms of
writing for adults,
it's just not something
that interests me.
The other thing is too,
I know a few writers,
and also a lot of
the magazines I
work with, use
writers of their own,
whether they're
freelance or staff.
So what I generally do when I
pitch a feature to somebody,
is I pitch story
ideas with it to just
make it a prettier
package for them,
so that the editors
don't have to do
as much research on their end.
And very often they go with
one of the points that I pitch,
and they'll assign
a writer to it.
And then the writer
almost always gets
in touch with me, which is very
common, because photographers,
we have all these direct
experiences with the situation
or with wildlife.
So they'll interview me, either
as a direct interview, or just
to get more information
to write their story.
AUDIENCE: So you give them
the photos plus ideas.
SUZI ESZTERHAS: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: So many of
the animals that you
photographed are endangered.
And I think there's a
pretty good awareness of how
climate change is endangering
those animals, especially
polar bears, et cetera.
But habitat loss
and invasive species
and other encroachments
because of the huge monoculture
seems like it's
equally threatening.
And I wonder if that's an angle
that you're trying to approach?
SUZI ESZTERHAS: Definitely.
Habitat loss, for so many of
the animals that I showed--
you know, orangutans are like
the extreme example for it--
but habitat loss
is something that
is affecting I think
every endangered
species that you saw photos of.
It's something that's
very challenging
to capture in an image.
We do see images of it, but it's
difficult to visually capture
that.
The biggest thing
in Africa is areas
that have been just grazed and
they're deserts, essentially
because of so many years
of improper grazing.
And then prey loss is
as bad as habitat loss,
if not worse, particularly,
obviously, for the predators.
But the prey loss is
huge when you are working
in impoverished countries.
Basically outside
the national park,
you don't see many things alive.
So again, I think
there's so many--
a lot of people, when the
death penalty was recently
announced by Kenya
for poachers-- people
are going to get the death
penalty for poaching,
and I had so many friends on
Facebook celebrating this.
And to me, it is a terribly
tragic, sad, sad situation,
because most of these poachers
that are doing the poaching,
they're low on the scale.
You've got the
person above them,
and then a middleman,
and then usually someone
in the government that's
getting all the money.
Those aren't the people that
are going to get executed.
It's the guy at the bottom.
And so, it's not
necessarily like the photos
you saw today aren't like guy
going to get meat and give it
to his children, it's much
more commercial than that.
It's like a drug trade.
It's big.
But he's a very,
very poor man who
does not have many
opportunities, if any,
besides poaching
for making money.
So it's very easy for all of
us to see it as black and white
in this country.
AUDIENCE: What should
Google be doing
beyond what they are doing
in the realm of conservation.
SUZI ESZTERHAS: That's
a really good question.
Maybe you should tell me that.
AUDIENCE: It's a secret.
[LAUGHTER]
I was going to say in the
realms of conservation
and of arts education
for kids and women?
SUZI ESZTERHAS: You know,
I think anything that
corporation-- first of all,
one of the things that I--
I do so much with kids, between
my children's magazines,
the children's books,
the Girls Who Click,
and to me, the biggest
problem in our society
is disconnection with nature.
It is so shockingly present
and such a serious issue,
because it touches on
local issues and global.
If a kid is not
connected to nature here,
they're not going to care
about lions in Africa.
So I think that
just establishing
a strong connection to nature
from the youngest age possible
is so critical.
I have a print shop.
I sell photos to children's
hospitals and to moms.
I purposely have an
economical line of prints
so that moms on low budgets
can afford to buy my work,
because I believe it's
important for those photos
to be on the nursery wall for
kids to see them on the wall.
Because honestly, I'm not
sure those kids are going
to be taken anywhere
where they're
going to see birds
and squirrels,
let alone larger
animals than that.
So I think that anything
that corporations
can do to get kids outside and
to get them connected to nature
is really, really important
on the most basic level.
Because I think with
our conservation,
yes, and fund-raising
is really important,
and working with adults
but so much of it is we're
preaching to the choir,
because we're reaching
people who already care.
The biggest thing, and
it boggles my mind,
because so many huge
conservation organizations do
nothing with children
anywhere in the world,
and that we're just
totally missing the boat.
All I have to do is look at
young kids on their iPads
and how much time
they spend a day
outside with their feet
touching the ground
and for many children it's zero.
I don't know the
actual numbers, but I
think for the majority of
children, it might be zero.
So I think that is the biggest
threat in this country right
now is that
connection being gone.
I can't imagine my
childhood without nature.
It was such a part of it.
And I just lived in the
hills in San Rafael.
I didn't live anywhere exotic.
In terms of what
else Google can do,
I think I'll leave that
to you to figure out.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]